what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have some major updates about the
Fantastic Four in the MCU we thought we
knew who the official Fantastic Four
team was because Marvel Studios
seemingly knew who they wanted however
it is now being reported that they could
not come to a deal with these actors
that they wanted so we have news about
some actors dropping out some actors
still hanging in there and one possible
actor who has been cast for one of the
roles of the Fantastic Four specifically
Sue storm and no it does not appear that
it is going to be Margot Robbie and it
doesn't look like our Mr Fantastic is
going to be Adam Driver so some fans I
know are going to be really happy about
this some not so happy but we're gonna
break down everything that you need to
know there have been a lot of reports
that have come out over the past 24
hours alone so we'll break down
everything that you need to know but
first big thank you to Rocket money for
sponsoring this video I have heard about
and how have wanted to try rocket money
for a very long time because they
claimed that they could possibly help
you save money and I have finally tried
them and they have indeed helped me save
money which I love Now Rocket money
offers many many helpful Financial tools
they can help you lower your bills set
budgets monitor your credit score but
what I really wanted to try out was the
canceling of unwanted subscriptions I
knew somewhere out there there were
subscriptions that I had had and never
canceled that I was still paying for and
that is exactly what they helped me find
I actually found out that I had two
subscriptions to one service that I
didn't need so they saved me money there
they also have a tool that shows you
when you're reoccurring payments are
going to hit your bank account and they
actually helped me lower my a t bill so
needless to say I am in love with this
app so if you'd like access to these
extremely helpful Financial tools you
can try it out today and unlock more
features with premium by going to
rocketmoney.com slash the cosmic Wonder
or you can click the link in the
description down below so there are many
parts to this update about the Fantastic
Four cast but the first part is about
Adam Driver and Margot Robbie who were
reportedly supposed to be locked in to
play Reed Richards aka Mr Fantastic and
Sue storm AKA The Invisible Woman of the
Fantastic Four it was reported that
Marvel Studios wanted these two to be
their main cast members and that part is
seemingly true however it looks like
they could not come to an agreement and
now they are out according to a tweet
and report from Insider Casey Walsh the
Fantastic Four cast has not been decided
yet the Tweet reads f4cast is still in
flux driver is out heard Robbie is out
Diggs isn't locked in yet so Marvel
Studios was in talks and really
negotiations with Adam Driver and Margot
Robbie but they could not come to an
agreement and based off of what we've
heard and a new report that we're about
to dive into they wanted a little bit
more money than Marvel could give them
Adam Driver and Margot Robbie are huge
names they're big actors and based off
of what we've heard it was looking like
the budget for the four main Fantastic
Four members alone was going to be
around 80 million dollars which is crazy
that means Adam Driver and Margot Robbie
most likely would have had 20 to 30
million paid to them for their roles and
apparently numbers like these were not
really doable by Marvel Studios or at
least they didn't want to it wasn't in
the budget apparently obviously there
are set budgets for movies but also
actors value themselves at a certain
worth and apparently they couldn't come
to an agreement between Marvel Studios
and Adam Driver and Margot Robbie and
according to a report from Insider Jeff
Snyder on the John Roca show he stated
that he heard that Adam Driver asked for
too much money that's why he's out
because Marvel Studios couldn't give him
the money or they couldn't come to an
agreement to give him the money in which
he was requesting we could probably
assume it was something similar with
Margot Robbie as well she's a huge star
right now about to come out as Barbie
She's Harley Quinn she is huge but it
sounds like David Diggs is still
negotiating right now to play the thing
and he's been in a decent amount of
projects as well including Hamilton so
he's not exactly a small name actor
however it looks like we might have our
Sue storm a report from Grace Randolph
seemingly tells us who our invisible
woman could potentially be over a couple
of weeks ago on June 12th she tweeted
this here's the issue with the Fantastic
forecast Marvel decided to go for big
stars for some reason yet now they all
want big paydays and movie has four
leads so 80 million for the cast alone
that's nuts what happened to the MCU
being in the star making business I'm
hearing all roles back in play again
others are being considered again and
this is what other insiders have
reported as well but Grace Randolph
stated yesterday in response to a tweet
stating but Vanessa Kirby is still
likely Grace said yes I found out more
recently that she likely land ended Sue
storm so this has not confirmed at the
time but Vanessa Kirby was in the
running to play Sue storm before the
actresses that we knew were in the
running to play Sue storm were Margot
Robbie Vanessa Kirby and Jody Comer
obviously Marvel studios's Top Choice
was seemingly Margot Robbie they tried
to work the deal out with her couldn't
come to an agreement and have now
seemingly moved on to their other
choices one of which was Vanessa Kirby
so there is a strong chance that Marvel
Studios could have locked in Vanessa
Kirby to play Sue storm I actually like
this Choice Jody Comer and Vanessa Kirby
were actually my top choices to play Sue
storm I definitely understand how Marvel
Studios could have wanted some really
big name actors to really help the film
but I do like sort of lesser known
actors to become really big because of
really amazing roles that they play in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and I hope
that is the case for Vanessa Kirby Now
Vanessa Kirby is by no means a small
actress she's in Mission Impossible Fast
and Furious Hobbs and Shaw and more many
people know who she is and I think that
she is an incredible actress she has
great skills and I think she looks the
part for Sue storm the same thing can be
said for Jody Comer She was recently in
free guy with Ryan Reynolds another
Marvel actor so plenty of people know
who she is both actresses are super
talented definitely talented enough to
play Sue storm and carry the Fantastic
Four Along with whoever they get to play
Reed Richards the thing and the Human
Torch and speaking of the Human Torch
really during this whole kind of casting
process that has been going on with
Marvel Studios for the Fantastic Four we
haven't heard much about the Human Torch
we've heard a lot about the other
members of the Fantastic Four but really
the only name that we've heard that has
had any type of solidification to it as
far as actually meeting with Marvel
Studios is Paul Moscow even reports that
have said that he is going to pass on
this said that he did meet with marble
however there have been contradicting
reports that state he is in the running
still to play the Human Torch although
we haven't heard anything lately in
regards to this and and like I mentioned
according to Casey Walsh the V Diggs is
still in talks to play the thing so
sadly it doesn't like we're going to be
getting our official Fantastic Four
casting announcement anytime soon and
when I say soon I mean in the next month
or so we know that Marvel Studios was
trying to sort of get this all finalized
before San Diego Comic-Con however they
are now not attending San Diego
Comic-Con so they are a little less
rushed at this point in time although
they do need to kind of hurry up so they
can get started with pre-production and
filming eventually but at the same time
we are expecting more delays from Marvel
Studios especially with the rider strike
so a lot is happening right now with the
Fantastic Four there are probably going
to be a lot of updates within the next
few months as they finalize the decision
of who they want their official cast to
be so be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest Fantastic Four
videos also today is the last day to
enter our giveaway for the month of June
we're giving away an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items and some DC
items as well the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month so if you don't win you
always get another chance if you want to
further support the channel you can
check us out on patreon we also have a
website and a Discord server you can
join and of course you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
foreign